Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Wilhelm Altern.
Ich bin hier auf die Sächsstation Arztinst Habendarzt tätig.
Ich werde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ich habe solche Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Oh, tut mir leid.
Ja, bevor wir über ihr natürlich
befürchten sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell
Ihre Namen aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ganz einfach. Ich heiße Anna Müller.
Anna Müller.
Ja, Frau Müller.
Können Sie bitte bis zum Ende das Gespräch aushalten?
Wie lange wird das dauern?
Ich habe jetzt die Schmerzen ja schon eine ganze Zeit.
Ja, ungefähr dauert es 20 Minuten.
Ja, so lange halte ich das noch aus.
Okay, dann machen wir sofort ein Unterbrechen.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel.
Ja, muss jetzt nicht sein.
Wir können erst mal das Gespräch führen.
Wir können erst das Gespräch führen.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Ja, Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41.
41?
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 20.09.82.
Also ich werde 41.
Okay, wie viel wiegen Sie?
68 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 m.
Okay, was sind Sie vom Beruf, Frau Müller?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Gut.
Darf ich Ihre Familie fragen?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Gut, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder haben wir.
Sie sind natürlich noch ziemlich klein.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie auch Schmerzen haben.
Aber was für Sie genau zu uns?
Ja, also es hat eigentlich so vor 3 Stunden angefangen.
Nach dem Mittagessen.
Da krieg ich mit einmal richtig, richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Wir haben Fankuchen gegessen, da habe ich natürlich ein bisschen dran getan.
Also ganz, ganz starke Schmerzen, die sind auch so krampfartig.
Und ganz, ganz starke Druckschmerzen.
Und das strahlt also in den Rücken und in die rechte Schulter hier rein.
Und das wird immer schlimmer statt besser.
Ich dachte, das würde vielleicht besser.
Ich habe so ein Buscopanzepchen genommen.
Das ist immer so ein Hilfe eigentlich.
Aber das ist überhaupt nicht besser geworden.
Hat das doch angeholfen?
Das hat fast nicht geholfen. Nein, ich habe immer noch solche Schmerzen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen, Frau Müller?
Also hier oben im Bauch, also oberhalb vom Bauchnabel und auf der rechten Seite.
Oberbauch, rechten Seite.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen bewerten auf eine Schmerzskala,
wobei eine Sehleichtung und zehn ist sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Also wenn das so richtig gerade wieder sich so zusammenkramst,
würde ich sagen, dann ist das so zwischen sieben und acht.
In der Richtung ist das schon, also sind wirklich deftige Schmerzen.
Man muss sich dann richtig so krummen.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da, Frau Müller?
Nein, eigentlich sind die mehr so kolikartig.
Also das ist immer kurzfristig und dann habe ich so eine Verschnaufpause
und dann geht es wieder los.
Okay, haben Sie so ähnliche Beschwerden früher gehabt, Frau Müller?
Ja, ich hatte das schon mal, aber längst nicht so schlimm.
Und das war immer, wenn ich mal so ein bisschen gesündigt habe
und ich habe immer so ein bisschen frischem Essen.
Also wenn ich mal so eine Sahnesoße gegessen habe
oder wenn ich Schlachsahne gegessen habe auf einem Kuchen,
dann ist mir das schon mal passiert, dass ich dann so dachte,
ja jetzt zwickst im Bauch, aber so wie jetzt, so ist das noch nie gewesen.
Okay, und seit wann hatten Sie diese andere Schmerzen?
Ja, ich würde sagen im letzten Vierteljahr ist mir das das erste Mal auch.
Ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Also übel ist mir schon, ja.
Gerade weil diese Schmerzen so krass sind,
weil ich eben auch so dieses unangenehme Gefühl habe,
dass ich eben zu fett gegessen habe.
Und ich musste mich auch einmal schon übergeben.
Einmal? Und wie sagt das Erbrochen aus?
Ja, das war das, was ich vorher gegessen hatte.
Einmal nur.
Okay, Frau Umler.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Also ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich so ein bisschen heißen Kopf habe, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie oder leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder?
Normalerweise nicht, nein, nein, nein.
Also jetzt, wenn es so ganz heiß ist,
und man das Zimmer nicht runterkühlen kann,
schwitzt man natürlich.
Aber normalerweise schwitzt sich eigentlich nachts nicht, nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich nicht.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Also heute brauche ich, will ich nichts zu essen, ja.
Normalerweise ist der ganz gut.
Aber also nachdem ich dann so ein fettes Essen mal gegessen habe,
dann ist das immer ein bisschen schlechter wieder.
Dann muss ich mal eine Pause machen.
Aber heute mag ich überhaupt nichts essen.
Dann habe ich überhaupt gar kein Appetit.
Können Sie gut schlafen, Frau Umler?
Normalerweise schon, aber ich habe versucht,
vorhin mich ein Moment hinzulegen,
um das irgendwie ein bisschen besser auszuhalten.
Aber ich konnte überhaupt nicht zur Ruhe kommen,
weil die Schmerzen so heftig waren.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen verstopft.
Ja, hin und wieder muss ich mal so einen Tropfen nehmen,
damit der Stuhlgang in Gang kommt.
Ja, Frau Umler, haben Sie früher irgendwelche chronische Erkrankten?
Leiden Sie eine?
Ja, also ich bin ja noch nicht so alter,
weil ich habe trotzdem schon ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und ich habe auch ein bisschen erhöhte Blutschädwerke,
der hat man festgestellt.
Eine Sache habe ich noch, das ist lästig,
habe ich nicht so oft, aber wenn es sehr unangenehm ist,
ich habe Migräne.
Da muss ich dann schnell ein Medikament nehmen
und muss Ruhe halten, dann geht es mir wieder gut.
Aber das habe ich zum Glück nicht so sehr oft.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie?
Dann nehme ich Triptanen.
Nehmen Sie noch einen Medikament gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ja, genau, dann nehme ich in der Lapriel.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das hat man so vor fünf Jahren festgestellt.
Also kurz nach der Schwangerschaft,
als das zweite Kind da war,
da hat man festgestellt, dass der Blutdruck ein bisschen hoh wird.
Ein Lappel, in welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Ich meine, das ist 12,5.
Morgen, abends.
Nehm ich eine morgens.
Und gegen erhöhte Blutschädwerke?
Ja, dann nehme ich Atomastatin.
Atomastatin.
Dann nehme ich abends eine.
Und Dosierung erinnern Sie sich?
Das sind 20 Milligramm.
20 Milligramm, vielen Dank.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert vom Ömel?
Ja, ich habe die Gebärmutter entfernt bekommen,
weil ich ganz extreme Blutungen hatte.
Das war dann Geburt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber das ist danach überhaupt nicht zur Ruhe gekommen.
Und nachdem die beiden Kinder da waren,
hat man dann gesagt, wir entfernen die Gebärmutter.
Wann war das?
Ja, das ist jetzt drei Jahre her.
Vor drei Jahren.
Und das war es als Operation?
Bitte?
Ja, sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden.
Okay.
Gibt es bei Ihrer Familie
irgendwelche chronische, bekannte Erkrankungen?
Ja, meine Mutter, die hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Und die hat auch jetzt im Alter ein Diabetes bekommen.
Und mein Vater ist früh gestorben,
der hatte ein Leberkrebs.
Leberkrebs, tut mir leid.
Wie alt war er, als er gestorben ist?
Ah, da war er Mitte 60.
Mitte 60, ne?
Mitte Ende 60, ja.
Okay.
Und er lebt noch Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, ja.
Ja, gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Anzündkind.
Und sind Ihre Kinder gesund, ja?
Meine Kinder sind fit gesund, ja, ja, Glückwunsch.
Gott sei Dank.
Frau Müller, wann waren Sie
besser seit beim Frauenarzt?
Ich gehe immer regelmäßig
zu Anfang des Jahres.
Das muss so im Februar gewesen sein.
Und alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja.
Frau Müller,
leider sind Sie unter Stress
oder etwas, was Sie selig belastet?
Nein, Schule macht mir eigentlich Spaß.
Und in der Familie ist es auch alles in Ordnung.
Ich bin nicht behauptet.
Okay, Frau Müller.
Ich möchte fragen, ob Sie rauchen Sie?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Super, ja.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder mal ein Glas Wein.
Oder jetzt im Sommer mal ein Glas Bier,
wenn man auf der Terrasse sitzt oder so, aber nicht viel.
Weil dann anlässend kann man sagen.
Ja, genau, wenn man mal mit Leuten zusammensitzt.
Aber jetzt nicht jeden Abend.
Und Frau Müller, nächste Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Ich muss standardmäßig fragen.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen, ja, da muss ich nur an der Schule gucken.
Aber nein, da habe ich selber nichts mit zu tun zum Glück.
Okay, ja.
Ja, wir sind fast fertig, Frau Müller.
Und ich möchte jetzt von Ihren Allergien wissen,
haben Siewiegendwärtsche Allergie oder Unfältiglichkeit?
Da ist mir nichts bekannt.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich schon mal auf irgendwas allererges reagiert habe.
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Muss ich gerade überlegen.
Nein, der Sommerurlaub ist noch nicht angetreten.
Nein, ich war noch nicht im Ausland.
Nein, in diesem halb Jahr noch nicht.
Sind Sie geimpft gegen Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona.
Auch gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten, das man so haben muss.
Okay, das ist super, Frau Müller.
Das war es.
Von meiner Seite.
Jetzt habe ich eine Frage, alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch etwas fragen
oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte jetzt eigentlich nur wissen,
woher das kommen kann.
Was Sie jetzt machen,
was für Untersuchungen Sie machen,
dass man rausfindet,
woher diese heftigen Bauchschmerzen kommen?
Natürlich, Frau Müller.
Eigentlich, es ist zu früh etwas zu sagen,
aber vermutlich habe ich ein Verdacht
auf einem Gallenwegen Entzündung.
Aber es ist nicht 100%ig.
Ich würde zuerst die körperliche Untersuchung
und dann von Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und danach ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen veranlassen.
Danach können wir ausführlich über Ihre Diagnose
und Therapiemöglichkeiten sprechen.
Okay, ja.
Gut, aber sind irgendwelche schmerzlichen Untersuchungen dabei?
Schmerzmittel, es wäre besser,
wenn Sie umaushalten,
aber wenn Sie nicht können aushalten,
dann kann ich ein.
Nein, meine Frage war anders.
Meine Frage war, tun diese Untersuchungen,
die Sie jetzt machen, tun mir die Wege?
Sind die schmerzhaft?
Ja, die Untersuchungen sind schmerzfrei,
dann ist gut, denn ich habe ja schon genug Schmerzen.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich denke, es ist ein gutes Gespräch.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich habe fast nix mehr auf dem Zettel,
was ich noch sagen könnte.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Fragen.
Doch noch etwas, ja, guck.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut oder Augen in Lästel
seit gelbisch geworden ist?
Hautverfärge ist mir nicht aufgefallene.
Haben Sie seit zwei Stunden,
seit drei Stunden beim Stuhlgang oder was so was?
Etwas Veränderungen, als gewöhnlich bemerkt?
Da habe ich keine Veränderungen bemerkt, nein.
Gehen Sie Winde ab,
Ach so, ob ich Blähungen habe, ja.
Nicht besonders, nö.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder ein Engigefühl in der Brust
oder Völlegefühl?
Völlegefühl, ja.
Also Brustschmerzen nicht,
aber die Schmerzen strahlen so in den Rücken
und hier in die rechte Schulter aus.
Ich habe keine Veränderungen,
ich möchte für die Finanzielle Diagnose eine Frage stellen.
Sie haben gesagt eine Operus-Entfernung,
Gebermutter-Entfernung.
Ja.
Können Sie genau beschreiben, zum Beispiel Bauch-Operation
oder vaginale Operationen?
Neuaginale Operationen.
Ja, das ist eine sehr große Frage.
Das ist ein Fall, den Sie auch noch nicht so oft gesagt haben, ne.
Ja, unsere Fall, das ist auch ein Fall.
Das ist kein Düsseldorferfall.
Es gibt entsprechend einen, der den
aber es ist nicht derselbe glaube ich.
Rosemarie Hagen, das heißt in Seldorf.
Wie heißt sie?
Rosemarie Hagen.
Ja, ja, genau. Aber sie hat irgendwie anderes Umfeld und andere Personal.
Ja, 1 bis 2, 41 Jahre.
Das ist sie auch? Das wusste ich gar nicht mehr.
Ja, gut.
Aber es ist jedenfalls aus einem anderen Telepool, nicht aus dem Düsseldorfer Pool.
Ja, danke.
Frau Müller darf etwas fragen.
Aber, Moa,
haben Sie bei der Historomie, ob Sie irgendwelche Blutprodukte bekommen?
Das kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber Frau Gerhard, Sie haben gesagt, viele Blutung.
Deswegen nehme ich an, ich habe welches bekommen.
Also, wahrscheinlich war sie schon ordentlich anemisch
und dann hat man die Gebärmutter raus
und wahrscheinlich hat sie da Blut bekommen.
Aber es ist nicht dokumentiert und ich habe es jetzt gesagt, ich weiß es nicht.
Können wir als Herzgeschef anfangen?
Altan?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie viele Zettel haben Sie? 20?
Unsere Anamnesebogen ist ein bisschen anders.
Deswegen wollte ich in anderen Reihenfolge etwas verordnen.
Aber ich habe nicht geschafft.
Guten Tag, Frau Obererstin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen
und ich würde sie Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, gerne, klar.
Frau Anna Müller ist ein 41-jähriger Patient.
Ist eine Frau, eine Frau, Patientin.
Ja, eine Frau, Patientin.
Frau Anna Müller ist eine 41-jährige Patientin,
die sich vorstellte bei uns
wegen seit drei Stunden bestehenden und plöselig aufgetretenen
Oberbauchschmerzen, die Schmerzen strahlen in die Rücken
und in die rechte Schulter aus.
Die Schmerzen würden krampfartig sein,
die Nährung abhängig.
Wo von abhängig?
Nährung abhängig.
Nach dem Essen aufgetreten sein.
Die Patientin klagte über eine Übelkeit
und musste einmal erbrechen,
dass Mageninhalte,
Magenspeisereste,
die Schmerzen gegen die Schmerzen
in die Rücken abhängen.
Sie hat das Buskupan,
ein Suppositorium,
ein Suppositorium einführen.
Welche wichtige Worte einführen,
ein einen Suppositorium einführen.
Ein einführen, ein einführen.
Die Fragen nach Nachtschweiß und Gerichtsverlust wurden verneint, aber die Patienten fühlten
sich fieberisch, aber nicht gemessen. Ich habe Übelkeit und Erbrechen, aber nicht neuser.
An vor der Erkrankung hat die Patientin Bluthochdruck seit fünf Jahren 2,5 mg morgens und erhöhte
Blutverdwerte, sie hatte auch Migräne und sie nahm Tritophane. Vor 3 Jahren wurde der Patientin
durchgeführt, oder wurde der Patientin die Gebärmutter enttell. Am besten ist die Transvaginale
ist direkt Tommy.
Noch besser.
Am Ende der 60er Jahren gestorben,
die Patientin bluthochdruck, und beide gynecologischen Anamnesen gaben die Patientin an,
dass sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt besucht besuche und alles war in Ordnung.
Im letzten Untersuchung war bei der letzten Untersuchung im Februar alles in Ordnung.
Vegetativen an einem Nese bis auf Schlafstörung und Appetitlosigkeit wegen dieser Beschwerden ist unauffällig.
Als Medikamente nehmen die Patienten Enelapil, Atolvastatin und Triptophan und Weiberdorf, Buscopan.
Nehmen Sie noch etwas?
Sie nehmen noch etwas, wenn sie verstopft ist.
Sie haben auch Verstoffung und Obstipation.
Was nehmen Sie?
Abfüllmittel.
Die Patienten haben nie geraucht und nur Alkohol, gelegentlich beiden Anlässen und hat keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Sie haben keine Allergien. Sie sind geimpft gegen Corona und Kinder-Heid-Krankheiten.
Gut, okay.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Nach einem anestischen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf Kolangitis aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Koledo-Koliteasis und Kolangio-Karsinoma in Betracht.
Wenn man nicht gleich ans Pankreatitis-Karsinom denkt, sondern akut eine Entzündung.
Akut Kolesus titis.
Ne, Pankreatitis möglicherweise als Differenzialdiagnose.
Wenn es nicht die Gale ist, dass es dann vielleicht die Bauchspeicheldrüse ist.
Gut, ja, was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Zuerst möchte ich die Patientin, der Patientin, Stationen aufnehmen und einen Zugang legen, damit wir sie, wie ihr, Flüssigkeit geben.
Und, was noch? Wichtig?
Gleichzeitig kann man Blut abnehmen.
Ne, warum soll die noch eine Infusion bekommen?
Infusion und Schmerzmittel.
Ja, du brauchst das gegen die Schmerzen. Die krümmt sich vor Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, okay, also gut, sie kriegt das gegen die Schmerzen und sie kriegt Flüssigkeit.
Okay, und was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch?
Im Blut möchte ich...
Ne, erst mal fangen Sie mit der körperlichen Untersuchung ein.
Ah, körperlich untersuchen.
Was?
Im körperlichen Untersuchung, ja, im rechten Oberbauch hat sie wahrscheinlich ein Empfindlichkeit im Macburni-Punkt.
Und vielleicht Hautfarbeveränderung?
Das meinte ich jetzt gerade mit, ne?
Gucken, genau, ist die Hautfarbe verändert?
Noch mal auf die Augen möglicherweise?
Ja, und das ist ja...
Genau, es gibt ein Klassiker, ein berühmtes Zeichen für die geilen Krankheit.
Ja, ich habe den Namen vergessen.
Murphy.
Murphy Zeichen.
Murphy Zeichen, um sicher zu sein, dass es die Galle ist.
Ja, genau.
Gut, ja, und was machen Sie...
Ja, da kommt er, genau.
Was machen Sie labortlich nicht?
Beide beim Blutbild möchte ich zuerst Entzündungparameter leber werden und zum Beispiel GGT, A, ST, wie Galen wegen Parameter.
Polistaswerte, das heißt.
Genau, amilase liepase bilirubi.
Amilase liepase, ja, pankeaswerte.
Genau.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter, technisch?
Zuerst möchte ich unbedingt ein Ultraschall veranlassen.
Und man kann da die Galen wegen sehen und ob die wegen erweitern.
Oder gestaut sind, ne?
Gestaut, ja.
Okay, gut.
Und was wäre, was wäre ansonsten noch als technisches Bildgebendes Verfahren?
Man kann ein Computer-Tomographie veranlassen.
Mit Konkret mit.
Damit können wir die pankeas und die anderen inneren Organe beurteilen.
Genau.
Und dann, ja, anschließlich, wenn wir ein Verdacht auf pankratitis, starke pankratitis, oder Obstruktion,
oder ja, wenn wir ein Verdacht auf eine Obstruktion im Galen wegen haben,
können wir mit endoscopik retrograd pankratico poulangioografi.
Ja, genau, RCP, das ist was gerade gekommen.
Damit können wir die Obstruktionen nachweisen oder erkennen.
Nachweisen erken und therapieren.
Ja, und das auch, genau.
Also, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie nehmen die stationär auf, Sie kriegt Infusion, Sie kriegt Analysie, kriegt ihr etwas zu essen?
Sie darf nicht essen, ja, Nahrung, Nahrung, Nahrung.
Genau.
Und was machen Sie außer der Analysie?
Sie krampft?
Als Analgetiker.
Zusätzlich zu der Analgetiker noch?
Metamison, Spasmolitiker.
Spasmolitiker, genau.
Gut, wenn man merkt, dass es eine Entzündung ist, was machen wir dann?
Wenn sie ein Entzündung hat, sollen wir mit einem Antibiotiktherapie anfangen.
Genau.
Und wenn sich zeigt in der ganzen Untersuchung, dass ein Stein der Auslöser ist, worauf kommt es dann an?
Steinlöse.
Ja.
Wie groß ist er, ne?
Ist er sein kleiner oder ist er sein großer?
Das entscheidet über die Therapie, ne?
Ja, ja, genau.
Gut, ja, dann sehen Sie mal zu, dass Sie zügig die Frau Müller untersuchen.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was dabei rausgekommen ist, welche Ergebnisse Sie rausbekommen, ob es wirklich die Galle ist oder doch irgendwas anderes.
Und dann werde ich hinterher natürlich, werden wir nochmal zusammen nach der Patientin gucken.
Ja?
Gut, alles klar.
Gut.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, an am Nese war flüssig, war gut, war vollständig.
Wenn es irgendwelche sprachlich ganz heftigen Probleme gab, habe ich immer gleich interveniert, habe ich immer gleich dazwischen geredet.
Wie immer war der Bericht jetzt nicht so flüssig wie das andere.
Das ist aber auch nicht ungewöhnlich.
Sie haben praktisch keine Zeit gehabt, sich irgendwelche Notizen zwischendurch zu machen und konnten nix vorbereiten.
Und das muss man immer berücksichtigen.
Und Sie haben aber eigentlich den Fall sehr schön geschildert.
Sie haben die deutsche Variante genommen.
Was mir gut gefallen hat, sie stellt sich vor Wegen irgendwas.
Und dann haben sie aber nicht, dann haben sie den Satz zu Ende gebracht.
Und dann haben sie neu angesetzt und haben gesagt, dann und dann sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
So und so ist die Qualität, dass man das nicht alles in so einen langen Bandwurmsatz am Anfang reinringt.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Dadurch konnte ich mir merken, was sie gesagt haben und ob sie komplett geschildert haben, was da drin war.
Das hat mir gut gefallen.
Eigentlich habe ich sprachlich nur eine einzige Sache.
Und zwar, da bin ich jetzt aber nicht sicher, sie haben gesagt gegen die Migräne nun sie tryptophran.
Das Medikament heißt aber tryptane.
Und das ist ein eigener Wirkstoff.
Und ich weiß, dass es tryptophran gibt, ich weiß aber nicht, ist tryptophran nicht irgendein...
Ist ein Aminosäure.
Das wollte ich noch sagen, das ist eine Aminosäure, eine essentielle Aminosäure.
Genau, also das Zeug heißt tryptane.
Das habe ich nämlich zwischendurch noch schnell gegoogelt, ob ich da jetzt auf dem falschen Dampfer war.
Ja, und sonst habe ich tatsächlich immer gleich interveniert und habe gesagt, wenn sprachlich irgendwas war,
also mit den Zäpfchen zum Beispiel, dass man das nicht einnimmt.
Ja, schmeckt nicht so gut.
Und sonst würde ich aber sagen, war das ordentlich, wirklich war.
Und sie haben nett mit der Patientin gesprochen, haben mir das gut erklärt, wenn sie Fragen hatte
und haben eigentlich auch sehr vollständig die Geschichte wiedergegeben.
Ich habe zwischendurch ein paar Mal reklamiert, dass wir die Fachbegriffe hören möchten.
Da sehe ich immer das mannende Gesicht von Dr. Gündes, dass ich da drauf achten muss.
Und deswegen habe ich da jetzt zwischendurch mal gesagt und das müssten sie natürlich dann in der Prüfung spontan verwenden, die Fachbegriffe.
Gut, ansonsten würde ich sagen, gucken Sie entspannt auf den 25.